ما البطوله بطوله الفرد الذي يخرج من قاع
الحياه ليصعد الى قمه قممها في فن من
الفنون فيكون صاحب زمانه وسلطان فنيه
بطوله الفرد التي تبدو احيانا كما لو انها
طفره اجتماعيه تنتقب لها الظروف واحدا
ينهض بجماعته على نهر يصعب تفسير حدوثه
فما كيميائها وما سرها
في البرازيل حيث الفقر وما يرتبه من
عنصريه الاجتماعيه هي بقيه من تاريخ الرق
في البلاد صنعت الظروف للخيال الشعبي بطلا
يعوض عن بؤس الحياه ونم الفاقه وانحسار
المستقبل امام عيون الملايين من البشر
المؤمنين
لم يكن البطل غير صبي اسود اسمه بيليه هو
صعود لا يشبه صعود غيره نجما في سماء
البرازيل فلا مال ولا طبقه ولا عرق يسعفه
لقد صعد الفتى بقدمه الساحرتين حتى ملئ
الافق البرازيلي لا يزاحمه عليه احد
البطل الفرد غالبا صنعه نفسه كان اراده
الله جاء به ليضيء الطريق المعتمته امام
الملايين من الصبيه الذين يتنفهم السواد
فاصبح سريعا ملهما
ومعزيا للذين تموت احلامهم في ازقه الحوار
الفقيره فالولد الذي لم يتجاوز عمره 17
عاما سيعود بكاس العالم الى بلاده من
البطوله التي نظمتها السويد عام 58
يصير اسبوع على كل لسان ويبقى مصدرا
لمسرات السحن السوداء والبيضاء على السواء
اكبر من طاقه عمره الغض فلا يعرف اين يذهب
بهذه النجوميه خارج ملاعب كره القدم
ما كانت البرازيل تملك ما تفاخر به في
ستنيات القرن الماضي شيئا اكثر من كره
القدم
يعودون الى تتويج البرازيل مرتين اخرىين
بكاس العالم مره عام 62 في تشيلي والثانيه
في عام 70 في المكسيك فيكون بذلك وحيده
زماني الذي يحقق الفوز بالكاس ثلاثه مرات
ان هذه النجوميه التي كان صيتها قد ملئ
الدنيا كانت خلال اكثر سنوات البرازيل ضد
التاتوريه بعد انقلاب العسكر في عام 64
على الحكم الديمقراطي
فعاشت البلاد تحت حكم عسكريه لم يتردد في
قتل وتعذيب واخفاء معارضيه على مدى 20
عاما حكم دكتاتوريون استثمر على نحو ما في
نجوميه وشعبيه بيليه كانه منجزر عسكري
الناقدون سيرته بيليه يقولون انه سكت حيث
ينبغي الكلام في وجه العسكر فلم يستغله
شعبيته ونفوده الكبير وصار الى حياه تام
تجاه ما يحدث في البلاد
وقد كشفت وثائق سريه حديثه عن تلك الفتره
النبي كانت تحت المراقبه من العسكر وانه
ربما كان قد تعرض لبعض الضوء
في يدفع عن نفسه تهمه الحياه بانه لا يفهم
في السياسه شيئا
في العام 75
سيترك بيليه البرازيل وفريقه سانتوس ليبدا
تجربه غايه في المخاطره والاثاره بانضمامه
الى فريق كوزموس النيوركي لكره القدم
وكره القدم لعبه لا تثير حماسه الامريكي
في شيء لان حماسته مرتبطه بلعبه الركب
العنيفه كانها تمثل بعنف اخر عنف متوحش
يتمظهر على نهر ماء في اللعبه الاكثر
شعبيه
لم يبقى بيليه عامين في كوزموس حتى جاءت
نجوميته بعشرات الالاف الى ملاعب كره
القدم خاصه بعد ان ينضم اليه نجوم كاس
العالم السابقون مثل الهولندي كرويف
والالماني بكمباور والبرازيلي كارلوس
البرتو بيليه
هو مؤسس كره القدم الامريكيه اما
الانجليزي الذين صنعوا كره القدم ثم رموا
بها العالم ستنتهي مهمتهم هنا
فسحرت كره القدم واساطيرها الاتون من
امريكا الجنوبيه هم وحدهم من سيمنحون هذه
الكره معنا ان تكون فنا وان تكون موسيقى
الفن